Fox News host Tucker Carlson is again facing
calls to resign or for Fox News to fire him
and or for boycott for advertisers to boycott
his program after essentially arguing that
the great replacement theory, sometimes known
as the white replacement theory, is real in
the United States.
But it's not racist to suggest that now.
It's very difficult to know where to start
because there's so much here.
But maybe to set the stage, I'll tell you
a little bit about great replacement or or
white replacement theory.
This is something that comes from France originally
in modern times, it's become a favorite of
white nationalists and white supremacists.
Originally in France, it was a theory that
white French people were being deliberately
replaced by non European people, including
Arabs, South Asians, Africans and others,
through a combination of importing people
from those countries, through immigration
combined with white French people being encouraged
to have fewer babies are having a lower birth
rate now.
It's just become a variable in the U.S. when
we talk about great replacement theory or
white replacement theory, it's a popular white
nationalist white supremacist idea.
And it not only is it, generally speaking,
white supremacist, it's also specifically
anti-Semitic in some of its flavors.
You might remember back in the Charlottesville
white supremacist rally back in twenty seventeen,
they were chanting, among other things, Jews
will not replace us.
That's what this is about.
That's a reference to exactly this idea.
So Tucker Carlson goes on and he's interviewed,
I think it's by Marc Stein and says Democrats
do want to replace Americans and they want
to dilute the population.
But it's not racist.
It's just true.
So let's just jump right into the first clip.
I'm laughing because this is one of about
10 stories that I know you've covered where
the government shows preference to people
who have shown absolute contempt for our customs,
our laws, our system itself, and they're being
treated better than American citizens.
Now, I know that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on Twitter become literally hysterical.
If you use the term replacement, if you suggest
that the Democratic Party is trying to replace
the current electorate, the voters now casting
ballots with new people, more obedient voters
from the Third World.
But they become hysterical because that's
that's what's happening, actually.
Let's just say it.
That's true.
So, Tucker, as a good faux populist or maybe
better said, as a right wing populist, he
knows enough to avoid saying this in the way
that is overtly racist.
He doesn't more subtly and with code when
he talks about replacing American voters with
voters from the Third World, he's talking
about voters that are mostly brown people
or black people.
That's it.
He's using coded language.
So not only is this straight up great replacement
stuff, it's also it's also nonsense.
And as I've said before, trying to win elections
by importing people who are slightly more
likely to vote for them in seven to nine years
when they get citizenship, if they get citizenship.
It's a terrible strategy, I think of the numbers.
And this is why, you know.
We very often react to the rhetoric and we
ignore the sort of factual or empirical basis,
75 million people voted for Donald Trump if
naturalized immigrants vote for Democrats
60 40, because remember, even though a lot
of people like Tucker want you to believe
that all immigrants are very left wing, the
truth is that, you know, Cubans and Venezuelans
are not very left wing.
There are lots of Asian immigrants that are
not left wing.
There are many Eastern European immigrants
that are not left wing.
Anyway, let's imagine that naturalized immigrants
by a 60-40 margin vote for Democrats.
That means that for every five hundred thousand
immigrants that become citizens, that's only
100000 vote margin for Democrats.
When you compare that to population growth,
when you compare that to people who move between
states, it's a drop in the bucket.
When you talk about bringing people in, having
them wait the five years before they can request
citizenship and then the additional period
to go through that process.
If this is how Democrats are trying to win,
it's a very stupid strategy.
Let's continue with the clip.
If look, if this was happening in your house,
if you were in sixth grade, for example, and
without telling you your kit, your parents
adopted a bunch of new siblings and gave them
brand new bikes and let them stay up later
and help them with their homework and gave
them twice the allowance that they gave you.
You would say to your siblings, you know,
I think we're being replaced by by kids that
our parents love more.
And it'll be kind of hard to argue against
you because look at the evidence.
So this matters on a bunch of different levels.
But on the most basic level, it's a voting
rights question.
In a democracy, one person equals one vote.
If you change the population, you dilute the
political power of the people who live there.
So every time they import a new voter, I'd
become disenfranchized as a current voter.
Now, by that logic, every time a new American
born kid turns 18, Tucker's vote is also worth
slightly less.
Every time an adult dies, Tucker's vote is
worth slightly more.
This is just life.
This is inflows outflows.
It's not evidence of any kind of grand, you
know, grand replacement theory.
Let's look at just one more clip here.
So I don't understand we don't understand
this.
I never want to make a racial issue out of
it.
Oh, the, you know, white replacement.
No, no, no.
This is a voting rights question.
I have less political power because they're
importing a brand new electorate.
Why should I sit back and take that?
The power that I have is an American guarantee
that birth is one man, one vote, and they're
diluting it.
No, they're not allowed to do that.
Why are we putting up with this?
So this is what happens when people fall for
populism.
In some ways in rhetoric, people will watch
Tucker and they'll say that there's a lot
there that sounds kind of like Bernie Sanders.
There's very there's a similar language that's
being used.
They're there for the people, there for the
middle class.
They criticized the elites, corporations.
Sometimes I'm with the little guy.
But then Tucker goes on a rant about Third
World immigrants diluting his voting power.
Black Lives Matter is going to take your house.
Immigrants make immigrants make the country
dirtier.
As he said, I don't know if it was six months
or a year ago.
We covered it.
This is the guy that some on the left are
idolizing saying Tucker is outflanking the
left on some issues.
There is a contingent on the left that is
completely fallen for this guy.
It's incredible stuff.
And as media have consequences for Tucker,
I imagine none that he's at Fox News to do
this type of stuff.
This is a feature, not a bug.
And while he's dealt with some advertiser
boycotts, anybody hoping for some kind of
repercussions to this, do not hold your breath.
We'll have more on this story and others from
today's show on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
You can find us The David Pakman Show.
And if you want to see a very strange hate
mail that I got this morning, follow me on
Instagram
at David Pakman.
T